un momento de celebración en medio de la
crisis humanitaria los migrantes que
acampan en la frontera entre belarús y
polonia recibieron esperanzados la
noticia de la llamada telefónica entre
la canciller angela merkel y el
presidente alexander lukashenko la
segunda en menos de una semana merkel
sugirió que se facilite el retorno de
los migrantes a sus países de origen a
través de acnur y la organización
internacional para las migraciones pero
esta no es una opción para muchos
ahora volver es difícil ya que es como
si no tuviéramos patria se ha ido un
sirio kurdo espera ansiosamente por ver
a sus padres quienes por décima vez
intentan llegar a europa
22 tú ves hasta soy un fan de kilómetros
estoy a 25 kilómetros de mis padres pero
no puedo ir a verlos llamarlos por
teléfono es muy duro unida en barca
knicks este sentimiento nos explica que
su familia termino separada en la
frontera su madre logró cruzar hacia
polonia pero su padre fue devuelto al
otro lado
mientras cientos de ellos expuestos a un
clima extremo fueron conducidos a una
bodega con calefacción para pasar la
noche la crisis en la frontera que
inició el 8 de noviembre estatizada por
las críticas a minsk de supuestamente
atraer migrantes para que ingresen a la
unión europea a través de la frontera
con polonia los países del bloque dicen
que el gobierno de lukashenko utiliza
esta táctica para castigar a europa por
las sanciones impuestas contra belarús
pese a los múltiples anuncios de
sanciones personas que huyen de la
guerra de sus países llegan a esta
gélida frontera con la esperanza de
iniciar una nueva vida en la unión
europea